[Music]
deanna is with us in jacksonville
florida hi deanna welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you sir
um i'm actually a truck driver i'm 49 my
husband will be 60 in a couple months he
was my co-driver
but he went out on medical issues two
years ago
and has been being totally disabled
um
we were fortunate enough to have a
long-term disability but we have to
fight for that each month for him to get
that check but he is getting his uh
1200 a month social security disability
and i did my and i make 837 a week bring
home and i am on salary and that is
after all the insurances
um
and uh life insurance comes out of my
check all that comes out ahead of that
number
okay so um my husband
is not on board
with me
um
downsizing all the credit and getting
rid of the card i've been
discovered to you about a month ago and
i had a conversation with him this
morning
he
his main focus is his everyday i'm only
home six times a year so i don't get to
go home he's at the house
and he mainly focuses on
him and what he's feeling
um and we also have two joint accounts
his check goes into his account
the rest of the stuff goes into my
account and i pay the majority of the
bills
his medications and his food and all
that kind of thing
so you're over the road
yes
yes and i'm i'm i'm the job that i that
i like they take care of us
they took care of my husband when he had
a problem they worked everything out and
helped us get his long-term disability
initiated so he's getting ssi and
long-term disability
while he meets the quote-unquote
criteria
okay
you guys are hard working
thank you i'm fortunate to have my
brother as my co-driver now
so um but my my credit card debt is uh
twenty thousand seventy seven dollars
we've got a seventy six hundred dollar
motorcycle that my husband really can't
drive anymore but we still owe the debt
on and if i if i turn that back in i
would owe
fifteen hundred dollars on it um to the
credit union
just to just to get rid of it i did
check on that
and we
um because i married a widower
um
we have been constantly paying off stuff
from his late wife
situation she died of medical issues
um
probably 10 or 12 years ago yeah because
we got married for eight and uh
we still are paying on a truck that he
thought that they paid for that he
didn't
um
all right let's pull up here for a
second christy
yeah
the the first thing that stands out to
me is
is the fact that y'all are operating in
separate lanes i know there's a lot of
variables there's a lot of debts there's
a lot of bills you got checks coming
from different places but the fact that
you all have separate accounts
and you are responsible for these things
and he's responsible for these things
that's a piece of it that's influencing
how you view
your approach to money more than you
realize it's not just the account that
the money sits in it's the way that you
approach it
and so
putting your money together
into one joint account where all the
income goes in and then you guys sit
down and do
uh a budget maybe for the first time
together starting these conversations
and putting money on the same place will
we'll give you something different to
work from whereas right now and it's
like well this is mine and this is yours
it almost implicitly you all have but
when he came off the road the thing that
you had in common
was gone
he sits at home you're not home ever
yeah and um he has a he has a set of
problems and a set of money you have a
set of problems and a set of money and
they're completely separated as if you
aren't married
is what you described
so even when you talk to him about being
on board with the plan
the framework that you're operating in
isn't even conducive to that plan i
guess is what i'm saying so i i'm not
saying he'll be super excited about the
plan if you were to combine your
accounts but i think that's an important
first step you're like the ideal
roommate you're never there
well i mean
my
we're very fortunate to find each other
and we wouldn't trade each other for
anybody i'm not suggesting i'm not
suggesting you divorce i'm telling you
that on a practical level your
day-to-day lives are so separated
that it's very difficult for you all to
have a common goal and so what you need
to do is step back from this and set a
common goal
for the two of you and the common goal
would include you being taken care of
and him being taken care of
so he he's got this he's dealing with
the emotions of not being able to work
and he was a hard-working dude and he's
not able to do that now and that's
emotional for a guy
it's emotional for most people
and um and then you're looking he's
looking at a bike over here he can't
ride anymore and you know you come home
from the road and go your best ideas
sell his bike and that that's that's not
gonna fly real good you know and i'm
sure i'm sure it was not a good
conversation so but the reason for that
is
i know that the reason you're not wrong
to tell him to sell the bike the bike
needs to go i agree
but the the point is is that he's got
this set of needs and once over here and
you've got a completely different set so
we you need to dial back from that and
you guys need to get on phone get on the
zoom call get get back in town
and reset and say okay
you're 65
when you're 75
and
i am 59
where are we going to be
where do we want to be what do we want
our lives to look like
are we still going to be operating the
way we're operating now with careers
with you gone all the time at 59 is that
what you want to do it's not a bad thing
you just have to decide to do that on
purpose
and where do we want to be with our
money
and then what is the steps
that we need to take with our money to
cause that
future out there
to occur well and i think you bring up a
good point because with her husband
going out on disability and i don't know
how recently that happened but the
effects of that
you're still dealing with and so i
wonder when you start to have a
conversation about a common goal even
asking him some questions like
in this transition what is something he
could get excited about and i don't know
what that is what how he spends his time
how he is there something he could do a
hobby something that that within his
abilities in this new reality that he
could get excited about and that will
then flow into the conversation about
money and goals but but in this
transition i'm sure it's been incredibly
hard but when you start talking about
values and dreams and the future like
you're saying dave then then you know
what to do with the money but but just
to zoom out a little bit because you're
right they've got they're they're
running in completely separate lanes and
you got to come together on what that
desired future looks like what is
something you're both looking forward to
and working toward and that brings you
together to work toward it in your
individual ways yeah and and you know
the thing is the umbrella can of what we
want our lives to look like should be
big enough to have both of you under yes
yeah you know and you say okay sharon
dave where you all want to be in 10
years okay we're 60 when we're 70 where
do we want to be what do we want our
lives to look like
oh crap we need to make some moves to
cause that to happen because that
desired future is henry cloud calls it
that that view of the future that vision
to occur
and if you don't make those moves
because what's happening now is you're
making all your decisions based on what
happens by friday
and what happens by friday for you is
distinctly different than it is for him
yeah very distinctly different but what
hap what you want together for 10 years
is probably a lot more similar than what
happens by friday yeah but then you can
both give up something that happens by
friday to get to the long-term goal
because the motorcycle's not in the
10-year plan yeah you know it's not but
you can come up with a new 10-year plan
yeah and something else could be in the
10-year plan right something else that
should be yeah should be in the 10-year
plan
so that that's the way to aim at it and
get it going in that direction hang on
i'll tell you what we're gonna do deanna
we're gonna put you into ramsey plus for
a year and let you and your husband work
on that that's something you can both do
and discuss uh while you're on the road
both of you can be taking the class at
the same time and that'll help give you
a way to talk through these issues